what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have to
talk about that venom post credit scene
since venom is finally out in theaters
venom let there be carnage is a fun
movie but unfortunately i think most of
everybody out there is going to be
talking about that post credit scene
more than anything else and needless to
say since this is a video explaining the
post credit scene there are going to be
some spoilers for the post credit scene
so if you don't want any spoilers for
venom let there be carnage or it's post
credit scene you should click away now
but if you've seen it or you just don't
care and you love spoilers you have come
to the right place and if you're new
consider subscribing and hitting that
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel videos like i said venom
was a fun ride it was nice to see
carnage on screen finally him going at
it with venom overall the movie was okay
but it was really fun to watch and the
post credits scene more than makes up
for anything that we saw in the film we
finally see venom on screen with
spider-man well on our screen because
spider-man was on a different screen for
him and make no mistake this is a mcu
post-credits scene yes sony and venom
are in it but this is for the mcu and
this has huge repercussions so in this
video we're going to break down this
post credit scene but also talk about
spider-man netway home the x-men and a
little bit about thor love and thunder
because it looks like maybe we could be
seeing some symbiotes in thor love and
thunder but let's start with that venom
post credit scene in the post-credits
scene venom and eddie find themselves in
a hotel somewhere tropical because we
know that they're on a beach most likely
in a spanish country because on the tv
they are watching a spanish novella
venom and eddie seem to be getting along
better than ever after the events of
venom let there be carnage and venom
asked eddie if he would like to see just
a fraction of what he's been through and
what his species has been through venom
says 80 billion light years of knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain eddie asks what he's
talking about and venom says i'll show
you just a fraction are you ready and
eddie says okay and as he says okay
everything around him begins to change
and kind of morph the tv lights up and
everything else kind of lights up around
him and changes into a different place
he's still in the same room but
everything around him is different and
much nicer he started off in a really
crappy hotel somewhere and ends up in a
really nice resort room he even sees the
towels folded as swans in which venom
says what the hell is that now eddie
brock says what did you do and venom
says it wasn't me this is super
important and i'll come back to this in
a bit we then hear venom go um and eddie
goes what we then turn to the tv that
shows jay jonah jameson for the
dailybugle.net
showing us that eddie and venom are now
in a different universe because where he
comes from there is the daily bugle an
actual print magazine but wherever he is
at now whichever universe he is in it is
now the dailybugle.net but after eddie
asks what venom says that guy and of
course it is tom holland spider-man on
screen which venom then licks bottom
line of this post-credits scene is that
venom and eddie are now in the marvel
cinematic universe they somehow by
whatever cause of events got dragged
into the mcu this is further established
when a man comes out of the bathroom and
he says dude what are you doing in my
room eddie looks around back and forth
doesn't have any excuse for what just
happened because he is completely
confused and says i don't know and that
is the post-credits scene now it's worth
noting that this man doesn't seem to be
all that surprised that a random strange
man is in his room he's very casual when
he asks what are you doing in my room
and this further backs up the fact that
they are in the mcu because the mcu has
dealt with their fair share of let's
just say weirdness the avengers have
fought multiple villains loki then
ultron then thanos came and snapped
everybody away and half of the people
got snapped back they've dealt with a
lot over time so this isn't really that
strange to this man now the tv confirms
that venom and eddie are in the mcu
because what is showing on the tv seems
to be very similar to the post-credits
scene of spider-man far from home now in
spider-man far from home tom holland
spider-man never had his mask off and
this is very important to notice because
this might not be the exact scene from
the post-credits scene this could be a
scene from spider-man no way home and
the reason that this is important is
because venom says that he didn't do
whatever just happened he was not
responsible for the multiverse shift
that means some other event brought them
into the mcu now we have multiple events
that could have done this if we do want
to link him to spider-man it could be
doctor strange's spell that went wrong
that brings all of the other multiversal
villains into the mcu we are not
expecting venom to appear in spider-man
no way home but perhaps he could appear
in a post-credits scene however if this
scene that they're showing on the tv is
in fact the post-credits scene from
spider-man far from home even though we
never saw him with a mask off that would
mean that the spell that doctor strange
did has not happened yet which means
that couldn't have been how venom got to
the universe but there are plenty of
other ways he could have we know that
wanda in one division did create a nexus
event we also know the big event that
happened in loki that kang made us aware
of and who knows what else is going on
in the background of the mcu that we
haven't been shown yet so there are many
ways that the multiverse shift could
have happened but the big thing to
really take away from this is that venom
is now in the mcu and it looks like he
wants to eat tom holland's spider-man
now andy circus and tom hardy have been
saying that venom and spider-man are
going to meet in the future they clearly
knew about the post-credits scene since
they did it and it's very clear that
when they're going to meet is very soon
i really wouldn't be surprised if venom
appears in spider-man no way home in
some shape or form and i wouldn't really
be surprised if that was the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home now as i mentioned this
post-credits scene is really an mcu
post-credits scene because what this
does is tell us that anybody from any
other universe could get dragged into
the mcu and when i say this i'm
primarily talking about the x-men from
the fox universe marvel studios and
disney now own all of the rights to all
of the fox characters all of the x-men
the fantastic four they're back home at
marvel studios in disney coincidentally
this means that not only can marvel
start their own new x-men but they can
also use the previous x-men from the
already established movies and based off
of all of the reports that we've heard
this is what they intend on doing in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness reports tell us that they are
going to bring back some old fox
characters like professor xavier these
characters will come into multiverse of
madness in some way shape or form
however it is reported that professor x
is going to be fighting wanda at some
point in time in the film now all that's
going to be super awesome to see but the
main point to take away from this is
that like ultron said in what if episode
8 with the multiverse anything is
possible and they just showed us that by
taking venom and bringing him into the
mcu the universe in which he was not in
before now venom has been around for a
very long time he said 80 trillion light
years and he says of hive knowledge so a
hive for the symbiotes this makes me
believe that somehow other symbiotes
could appear in the mcu and when i think
about that i think about thor love and
thunder because of gore the god butcher
gore the god butcher in the comics ends
up possessing the all-black necro sword
and what that really is is the very
first symbiote he would take this from
an evil deity known as null who recently
fought another god in which both of them
got very injured in which gore took the
necro sword realizing that gods were
real but didn't actually help people out
he would take the sword and go use it to
kill other gods hence his name gore the
godbutcher the necro sword is how he is
able to kill gods and we know that he is
the main villain of thor love and
thunder so now that venom has been
dragged into the mcu and sony and marvel
are playing super nice with each other
right now it is possible that we could
see some type of symbiote in thor love
and thunder and could even perhaps see
the all black necro sword which i think
would be pretty freaking cool but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below let me know what you
think about the venom let there be
carnage post credit scene now that venom
is finally in the mcu let me know down
below don't forget to like this video
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]
you